Stephen King delves deep into the
psyches and lives of even as most
marginal characters which can make
adaptations of his stories into a visual
medium pretty tricky his magnum opus
Ed's has been brought to both TV and the
big screen how do the cast stack up
float on down and see which came first
the fear of clowns or Stephen King's
monstrous Pennywise at this point it
almost doesn't matter since the two are
so inextricably linked in the global
consciousness and the nightmares of
children and adults alike during his
first encounter with Georgie damn bro in
the sewer in 1957 penny wise hats yellow
eyes that turn blue as he stalks King
rights the face of the clown in the
storm drain was White's there were funny
Tufts of red hair on either side of his
bald head and there was a big clown like
smile painted over his mouth if George
had been inhabiting a later year he
would have surely thought of Ronald
McDonald King goes further he was
wearing a baggy silk suit with great big
orange buttons a bright tie
electric-blue flopped down his front and
on his hands were big white gloves like
the kind Mickey Mouse and Donald Duck
always wore when Ben Hanscom sees the
clown shortly after he is also wearing a
floppy yellow bowtie and notices that
their clown casts no shadow 25 years
later when Pennywise attacks Adrian
melon under the bridge
King reiterates earlier bozo and Ronald
McDonald comparisons but adds thoughts
later consideration and caused him to
think the clown really looked like
neither King also describes great big
teeth like those of a circus lion those
definitely made it into the films
[Music]
also known as big bill and stuttering
Bell even to his friends the unofficial
leader of the losers Club is described
not with the dark brown hair he has in
the film but as having bright red hair
and blue eyes after the first attack on
penny wise in the house on niebolt
Street bill gives his shirt to Beverly
King rice that's when shirtless bill had
a narrow chest the visible track of his
ribs and sunburned freckled shoulders
even when they're young Richie Tozier
abuses that John F Kennedy reminds him
of Bill older bill as depicted in his
author photo on the back of one of his
novels is described as a bald man
wearing glasses King writes that he is
tall and has a certain presence bill is
already building already inclining a
bits of what fats
he speaks slowly in company and at times
seems nearly inarticulate another
description reads his eyes magnified by
the lenses of its glasses looked
thoughtful that part lines up with how
old a bell appears in the 1998
miniseries played by Richard Thomas but
what doesn't fit is quote that's read
fine hair that he had begun to lose when
he was only a college sophomore Thomas's
version of the character that only has
hair but enough of it to pour back into
a ponytail while Pennywise the clown had
many many victims detailed in the pages
of King's it the first he properly meets
his bills that'll brother Georgi his
physical description is notably sparse
all we know at first is that Georgi is a
small boy in a yellow slicker and Greg
galoshes and he is just six years old
much later in the story as Pennywise his
campaign of terror begins ramping up
against the losers in earnest King
describes Georgi in more detail from a
family photo album in the picture George
is wearing a crewneck shirt his flyaway
hair was slicked down with water he was
grinning revealing two empty slots in
which new teeth would never grow as
Pennywise uses Georgie's goes to Tom
bill he appears with his yellow slicker
covered in blood as well as his arm
missing both movie adaptations of its
end up faithfully portraying a Bills
little brother which was easy to do
since he subscribed so ambiguously
like Baylor Beverly has bright red hair
that Kings novel describes us or burn
coppery and deep red sometimes has blond
highlights the dim Irish fire of her
hair as a young girl her hair was
shoulder length and she wore it pulled
back in a ponytail most of the time
Beverly has quote gray blue eyes
naturally red lips and creamy and
blemished child skin with a tiny spray
of freckles across her nose as a child
her wardrobe is described as cheap
sweaters penny loafers and deal fitting
tartan skirts that probably came from
the Salvation Army thrift bucks
Beverly often has huge bruises on her
face and arms a signature of her
father's abusive handiwork as an adult
Beverly is described as a gorgeous woman
with a slim but well-endowed figure
she's grown her red hair down to her
waist and her fingernails are kept needs
but brutally short shades of these
descriptors are evident in all of
Beverly's four trails on screen except
for the short nails as a young man Mike
Hanlon is described as slim and
well-built
as well as fast and agile factors that
had saved him from several beatings at
Henry Bowers hands Mike has a tight cup
of hair and often wears corduroys a
t-shirt and black high topped cats
Bill's assessment of Mike when he
returns to Derry reveals the extended
trauma Mica's experience her remaining
in the haunted town they'll remember the
boy who had been about five feet three
trim and agile before him was a man who
stood about five seven he was skinny his
clothes seemed to hang on him and the
lines of his face said he was on the
darker side of 40 instead of only 38 or
so Mike also wears glasses as an adult
and he has a scar across his chest from
when the werewolf form of Pennywise
scratched him at the ball streets his
portrayal on-screen in the 1990
miniseries is truer to the book than a
new sketchy movies but chapter one gives
much of his motivation to Ben Hanscom
and chapter two has hit him harder by
the trauma of his youth as a child Ben
Hanscom was described as larger than any
of the interrupt Asians have shown Kings
detailed description paints him as an 11
year old kid with a can roughly the size
of New Mexico the boys at school bully
him for his weight and King writes that
Ben had four baggy sweatshirts in which
to drown his 210 pound body one brown
one green and two blue odor Ben couldn't
be more the opposite of his younger self
King writes that Ben is lanky sunburned
dressed in a chambray shirt faded jeans
and a pair of scuffed engineer boots but
faints Quinn lines around the corners of
his eyes but nowhere else basically
somewhere between Clint Eastwood and a
Wrangler commercial Wrangler
they are clinic western jeans in
contrast to his fellow losers who were
too psychological tolls of their trauma
on their faces Ben looks perhaps 10
years younger than his actual age which
was 38 when the grown-up loses meat and
dairy for dinner
King describes Ben had gotten thin his
clothes clung to a body with four slim
and narrow hips he wore a bracelet with
heavy links on one wrist not gold links
but copper ones Jay Ryan is older Ben in
chapter 2 fits this bill far more than
John Ritter did in the 1990 miniseries
Kings descriptions of young Stanley
don't give even a small hint as to how
tragically its story will end if
anything he initially seems like one of
the most likely characters to make it
through the battle with penny wise King
rights as always he looked small slim
and free to naturally needs much too
neat for a kid who was barely 11 he
looked instead like the world's smallest
adults then he smiled and the illusion
was broken Stan often wears a slicker
and carries his bird book and binoculars
with him in the brief time we have with
older Stan before he takes his last bath
his wife describes him as ropey with
muscle with a hip short way of walking a
taste of bell-bottom jeans on his days
off and the last ghosts of adolescent
acne still on his face he keeps his
black hair short and like many of the
other losers
wears glasses as an adult there are
shades of this version in Andy bean
Stanley in its chapter two but almost
none at all in the 1990 miniseries like
Georgie dem bro the physical description
of Richie Tozier is surprisingly barren
that it's novel considering he's one of
the key seven characters King writes
tosia was a scrawny kid who wore glasses
his magnified eyes from behind the thick
lenses with an expression of perpetual
surprise he also had huge front teeth
that earned in the nickname Bucky beaver
even older Richie only reflects on his
appearance about his younger self when
he looks in the mirror he saw a boy who
wore glasses a thin boy with a pale face
that had somehow seemed to scream hit me
go on and hit me here are my eyes so
blue and magnified behind these hateful
hateful glasses
these horn-rimmed specs one bomb of
which has held on with adhesive tape
thin wolfhard glasses in each chapter
wad look a lot like that description
except for the little detail of the tape
holding them together a crucial reminder
of exactly how much he suffers at the
hands of Henry Bowers older rich he
trades his glasses for contacts until he
returns to Derry and Pennywise starts
messing with his eyes but by then he's
dead longer than I'd dug out of the
losers Club with specs most of the other
losers wear glasses too
thanks to his mother's domineering
attitude that constantly has Eddie in
and out of the emergency room the young
boy's face is described as small and
pinched and worried an old man's face
aging doesn't do Eddy many favors at all
King describes adult Eddy as a short man
with a timid rabbity sort of face most
of his hair was gone what was left to
grow in listless piebald patches there
was a little snow on Eddy's mountain
already when they see each other again
as grown-ups big Bill's assessments of
Eddy is just as harsh Eddy had grown up
to look quite a little bit like Anthony
Perkins his hair was short worn in an
out-of-date style that have been known
as Ivy League in the late 50s and early
60s he was wearing a loud checked sport
coat but the watch on one wrist was
protect Philippe and the ring on the
little finger of his right hand was a
ruby the stone was too hugely vulgar and
too ostentatious to be anything but real
in shorts Eddy on-screen has never
looked much like the character on the
page
Pennywise was not the losers only
nemesis that unfortunate honour also
goes to Henry Bowers about whom King
writes
Henry was a big boy even for 12 his arms
and legs were thick with farm muscle
henry puts in at least 30 hours a week
hoeing weeding planting digging rocks
cutting wood and reaping he continues
Henry's hair was cut in an angry-looking
flattop short enough for the white of
his scalp to show through he butch waxed
the front with a tube he always carried
in the hip pocket of his jeans and as a
results the hair just above his forehead
looks like the teeth of a nun coming
power mower interestingly
Bowers typically wears a pink motorcycle
jacket with an eagle on the back a pink
jacket that nobody ever mentions because
the one person who did got beat so badly
Henry put him in the hospital Henry has
black eyes that sparkle especially when
committing violence
who you are get some new material champ
yes later after spending most of his
adult life in a psychiatric hospital
Bowers had put on weight and his skin
had quote an unhealthy tallowy hue
sagging in the 1990 adaptation Henry's
hair turned white from the trauma of
encountering Pennywise butts in the
mousse Ketty adaptations older Henry
does resemble the description in King's
novel check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]